hey klick zoom hey Amy meine Frage an
dich Amy sm hattest du ein bisschen Aufzählungszeichen
wegen deines Nachnamens weißt du, dass
McDonald's und die Firma McDonald's so
etwas sind, vielleicht als du
jünger warst oder in der Schule vielleicht und jetzt in
deinem Leben als Sängerin  und Songwriter Ich wurde
nie wegen meines Namens gemobbt und der
Name McDonald ist einer der häufigsten
Namen auf der ganzen Welt. Ich bin definitiv
in Schottland, also ist es sehr normal und mein
Name ist eigentlich ganz anders als
der von McDonald, also Fast Food  Kette mein
Name ist ma c klein d als ich dort war
nce Hauptstadt d und es ist eigentlich ein
ganz anderer Name und er ist eine
etwas seltsame Frage